this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 13 with Echo Charles and me Jocko
willink good evening all right so
I was in a house
in Iraq
in my first deployment to Iraq so 2000
this was either 2000 for year 2004 and
it was a small farmhouse out in the
middle of nowhere
I forget the full background of the
scenario but it was something like one
of the Elder sons of this particular
family had been mixed up in some kind of
insurgent operation so we're out there
looking for this kid
and by Kid I mean you know 25 year old
military age male
we raid this house looking for this
this military age male and we get the
building cleared and the guy wasn't
there but you know his family was there
and so we've got The Interpreter and the
interpreters kind of
talking to family
and there's some kids there and so the
guys are giving some you know
candy to the kids and this kind of stuff
looking around
the house was basically one big room
but basically one big room and there was
mattresses on the floor in one of the
corners this is real common over there
for some of the
people on the lower end of the uh
economic
spectrum they they would just sleep with
mattresses on the floor and they'd have
blankets and mattresses kind of piled up
and that's where the family would eat so
that was in kind of one corner then
there was a table for eating
with a couple chairs around you a few
chairs around it you know four or five
chairs around this table and then there
was another table next to it
uh that was sort of I guess it would be
considered the counter space of a
kitchen and then there was a a sink with
a water faucet right so it was there was
some form of running water
and a sink of some kind you know it's
just picture like an old school kind of
porcelain thing
all pretty old-fashioned sink but is
working and then
in between the table
where the kind of counter table where
they would prepare food and the table
where
they would eat and those were separated
by call it six feet five feet six feet
there was a slit Trench
to go to the bathroom
now okay it was so what's a slit trench
so what this is this is a a little ditch
probably about
six inches wide
maybe eight inches wide probably about
six inches deep
about two or three feet long and it's
perpendicular to the wall and then when
it gets to the wall there's a hole
through the wall
and alcohol is a big
a big pit
and it's a sewage pit
actually these are pretty common in Iraq
uh they're weak weak I don't know what
they're called we called them
we call them [ __ ] pits because they were
just big pits that were filled with
sewage
kind of like almost an above ground
septic tank right you go to the bathroom
in there and over time I guess maybe it
goes away I'm not 100 sure
but there's this church there's there's
no running water down this trench this
is just
in the concrete in this concrete floor
and it didn't really have too much of an
angle to it
it's I mean at least not enough of an
angle because most of the
most of the excrement and urine was or
or I shouldn't say most there was a
bunch of excrement and urine in this
slit Trench
and I remember sitting there thinking
about this how just thinking how much
how messed up this is right this is
this is messed up and here were these
people
and they were just normal people I mean
sure they had a son that had been Rogue
right it'd be like if your kid your son
got wrapped up in some gang and all of a
sudden the cops try and come and find
about your house and you're looking
around going wait a second we're just
normal that's who this family was they
were they were just kind of normal
my interpreter was having a good
conversation with him and that you know
he was kind of asking what their
background was when's the last time you
saw your son and stuff like that but it
was also you know what do you do here
and they were farmers and they lived
there for a long time you know we're
trying to figure out do you have any
other houses where your son could be
they're like no we don't have any other
houses this is where we live this is our
farm this is what we do they had they
had actually money they had you know a
couple I think they had an opal and then
a they had a couple like a car and a
truck so they they're able to get around
they're obviously make money you got to
get gas and stuff like this so they have
this is this is a family that's kind of
put they've got some things going for
them
right they got a business they got
Vehicles they got housing
and yet with all that they have this
this
slit trench of [ __ ] that divides they're
basically their kitchen and their dining
room
and now listen it
it's it's in these types of rural areas
when you get out into these rural areas
of Iraq there's it's pretty common that
they wouldn't they may or may not have
running water right there may not may or
may not have Plumbing
but this
this level of kind of unsanitary
conditions was not something that I saw
very often most of the places most of
the Farms look when you were in Baghdad
and stuff they have toilets and
everything else no Factor but you get
out to the the rural places
they would have like an outhouse or
something right I mean it's you got to
deal with it right you got to deal with
it so they'd have an outhouse or they'd
have a separate room in the house they'd
kind of box something in and then
there'd be a slit trench in there
but they'd have some way of making the
consistent human issue of waste
they would have a way of making it
either sanitary or somehow acceptable
right they would figure it out
and this family was didn't do that again
this is normal these are people that I'm
thinking this was what was so
mind-boggling to me it wasn't like these
people were the inbred you know whatever
it wasn't like they were they were some
stereotypical people that couldn't
understand they were normal people
so
it was it also wasn't like this family
had just arrived right because The
Interpreter is talking to him
they'd been there for a while
I mean look if you showed up at a place
if you if you moved in three days ago
and you haven't got a chance to figure
this out yet you know okay I get it
right it takes a little time but this
was their actual home where they'd been
they'd been there for a long time for
I mean I'm assuming maybe a couple
Generations may but at least
at least many years many many years
and they still hadn't like remedied this
problem
and
so
if you look at the other side of
what well not the other side but for us
in the U.S military all the times in the
SEAL Teams included we would go and we
would move into Old buildings
we'd move into Old buildings that were
um
you know former whatever former regime
elements or whatever we'd move into
buildings we'd take them over maybe
they're just hangers right whatever we'd
move into buildings we'd take them over
and oh as soon as we'd move in somewhere
we'd start like doing a reorg and fixing
stuff and rebuilding things and
retrofitting whatever we could to make
these things more livable we do that
almost instantly
and yet here was this
situation where no move had been made to
improve the scenario and look I'm
talking about a place in Iraq but you
this happens in America right you go
watch a
go watch a
an episode of cops right and you see and
you look at what's going on here there's
a bunch of little things that could be
you know squared away in this particular
situation
why is this like this
and the reason that I'm saying this
is because it kind of left a mark on me
it's something that I it's something
that I that left a mark on me in two
ways the first way that it left a mark
on me
because I thought to myself well maybe
they maybe these people for whatever
reason just didn't understand the
situation maybe this was just what was
normal for them
you know if you this is how you were
raised this is what we do this is how it
works
but but I actually don't even believe
that
because what what makes that hard to
accept
what makes that hard to accept is that
there's [ __ ] in your kitchen that's what
makes it hard to accept
right there's differently hey you get
raised in a certain cultural way or you
get raised by a family that whatever
they're doing and that's what you
understand the reality to be and that's
how you grow that's how you grow up and
you think that's oh that's the way it is
but you don't really
you don't really need to get taught
that that you know having a having a a
trench to go to the bathroom in in your
kitchen you don't need to get no need to
tell you that's a that's unsanitary no
need to tell you that no one needs to
tell you it's not hygienic to do that
right you don't need to get told that
it reeks it smells bad
and so you look at it you go you know
what this smells really bad I'm gonna do
something different we're gonna make a
change here that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna make a change here
this this system of sewage disposal
could use some improvement I'm going to
try something else
and then you do it
you try something else you you I don't
know what it is maybe you build a room
around it maybe you move that thing
outside there's a bunch of different
things you can try
but that but so that's the other Mark
that got left on me is
something stinks
then fix it
if something stinks in your life if
there's something wrong then fix it
now look I get that there's things that
there's some things in life that we
can't fix
right you can get a disease you can have
acts of God unfold upon you with no
mercy and there's you you well then what
you do is you
you face those things and you take
ownership of how you respond to those
horrible events when they happen
but
oftentimes there's things
in our lives that stink
and we can actually do something about
it
we can actually do something about it so
when I see something in my life when I
see something in my life that needs to
get fixed I I might I might blow it off
once and go ah you know no big deal and
then I think
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
so just email
s at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then we will see
you mobilized
Underground
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground